merci merci beaucoup georges la question
du terrorisme et malheureusement et doit
être malheureusement au coeur de nos
préoccupations nous savons que la france
est une cible
peut-être la première au monde nous
savons que le risque aujourd'hui est
maximal et la question n'est pas de
savoir s'il y aura d'autres attentats
mais hélas
et c'est tragique de dire ça de savoir
quand ils auront donc face à cette
situation qui est décrite par tous les
spécialistes qui est connu par nos
services de renseignement il faut passer
à une échelle beaucoup plus forte dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme
nous l'avons réclamé personne
personnellement avec à l'assemblée
guillaume larrivé claude goasguen
georges fenech de façon systématique
depuis 2012 depuis la ferme ra
rappelons-nous au moment de l'élection
présidentielle
c'est assassinat ignoble horrible
montauban toulouse nicolas sarkozy
demande une grande loi d'unité nationale
contre le terrorisme le candidat
hollande lui refuse tout cela est
reportée à décembre 2012
déjà huit mois de perdus avec une loi
très faible qui crée simplement un délit
de terrorisme pour ceux qui sont partis
combattre à l'étranger il faut ensuite
hélas de nouvelles tragédies et
notamment les attentats des 7 8 et 9
janvier pour que le gouvernement se
réveille
depuis trois lois antiterroristes je
veux souligner que nous contrairement à
la gauche qui avait une attitude
démagogique irresponsables qui avait
refusé a dit colas sarkozy est bien les
moyens juridiques pour s'adapter au
climat anti terroriste
eh bien nous avons voté à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat ou au parlement
systématiquement ces trois projets qui
sont devenus lois antiterroristes y
compris celles sur le renseignement
aujourd'hui la situation quelle est elle
nous avons triplé le nombre de personnes
qui sont parties ou qui sont impliqués
dans les filières djihadistes six ans au
1er janvier 2014
hazim en 2000 aujourd'hui il y en a en
gros 50 de plus chaque semaine nous
voyons aujourd'hui qu'il ay a quasiment
dix mille personnes qui sont dans les
fichiers des services de renseignement
plus de 10000 11400 et qui démontre des
signes de radicalisation
nous voyons ces personnes qui sont sur
les théâtres de combat extérieur qui
sont comme on dit parti faire le djihad
et face à cela qu'elle est la réponse
j'ai travaillé à la tête d'une
commission denquête pendant six mois
au premier semestre nous avons fait des
propositions très concrètes aujourd'hui
quasiment aucune de ces propositions ne
sont en train d'applications quasiment
aucune ce qui m'a conduit d'ailleurs à
écrire au président de la république et
un mois pour lui demander des comptes là
dessus et puis nous avons entendu les
grands discours de la gauche
avec cet appel à l'unité nationale on
est d'accord
nous avons entendu des annonces beaucoup
de discours de monsieur cazeneuve
beaucoup de paroles très fortes du
premier ministre à l'assemblée mais les
actes où sont les actes aujourd'hui nous
avons une première réponse le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur
augmente de 0 96% pour 2016 c'est à dire
quasiment rien on nous avait annoncé des
milliers de recrutements on voit qu'ils
sont différées qu'ils interviennent en
fin d'année et c'est normal pour former
un policier pour former un agent des
services de renseignement il faut
plusieurs années
donc on est loin du compte entre le
discours et les actes
alors face à cette situation il faut des
réponses très concrètes nous voulons les
apporter avec nicolas sarkozy y est et
sur des sujets je vais prendre trois
exemples très clair très concret d'abord
les djihadistes qui partent vers la
syrie et vers l'irak
ceux qui défient pour des raisons
religieuses ceux qui habitaient par cet
extrémisme par l'islamisme radical défi
la nation ceux qui combattent bien sûr
contre des armées syriennes ou irakienne
mais surtout qu'ils combattent aussi
contre l'armée française ne l'oublions
pas qui sont des traîtres à la nation
qui ont défié la république qui sont
porteurs de messages de destructions
contre notre civilisation a bien cela
ils ont chaud
dit de partir et je le dis très
clairement il faut dans la plupart des
cas quand ils sont binationaux empêcher
leur retour
très clairement nous ne pouvons
accueillir ces personnes qui sont partis
combattre contre la france sur le
territoire national ceux qui sont
français et c'est ce que nous proposons
ceux qui sont français doivent être
placés en détention et ceux contre
lesquels il n'y a pas d'éléments
juridiques suffisants eh bien on doit
recourir à une procédure qui est une
procédure d'exception mais à situation
de guerre mesures d'exception il faut
des procédures d'internement
administratif
aujourd'hui un maire et un préfet peut
placer en situation d'internement
administratif quelqu'un de troubles
psychiatriques
par contre quelqu'un qui menacent la
nation qui est identifié par nos
services de renseignement qui peut
demain commettre un attentat au n'a pas
de moyens juridiques de le placer dans
un centre de rétention et bien moi je
suggère que c'est là dessus qu'il faut
faire jouer le principe de précaution
plutôt qu'en matière environnementale
parce qu'il s'agit de protéger notre
société ensuite je propose très
clairement avec donc l'expulsion des
binationaux qui sont partis faire le
djihad en tout cas l'interdiction de
retour la détention systématique pour
ceux qui rentrent l'ouverture de centres
de rétention de sûreté pour ces
personnes qui présentent un risque ou
pour les personnes qui sont condamnées
qui ont été condamnés pour des actes de
terroristes et il y en a aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont sortir de prison y compris
certaines qui sont impliqués ou
soupçonnés d'être impliqués dans
l'organisation des attentats du mois de
janvier et bien ces personnes parce
qu'elles représentent un risque majeur
viscérale pour la nation
on doit pouvoir là aussi protéger notre
nation et les placer après la détention
comme nous l'avions fait lors de la
précédente législature dans des centres
de rétention nous l'avions fait pour les
criminels dangereux des mesures de
rétention de sûreté
il faut pouvoir le faire aussi pour les
terroristes
parce que le risque est majeur et parce
que notre devoir notre responsabilité
c'est de protéger nos concitoyens et
disons le clairement aujourd'hui les
mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement ne sont en rien à la
hauteur des risques des menaces des
dangers qui pèsent sur notre société
voilà ces propositions très concrètes
que nous devons et que nous voulons
aujourd'hui formulée en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme